by the way there are people who don't  believe or recognize that ancient  peoples had the same brains as we do I  mean they're human beings right so you  can ask how long does it take to find  Bluestone and drag it you know dozens of  miles to a location it takes long but it  doesn't take forever no so this is not  an impossible thing to imagine but  people who do find it hard to imagine  they're quick to say what Chuck that it  was aliens aliens yeah so just because  you can't figure out how ancient peoples  did it doesn't mean aliens help them  maybe the ancient peoples were cleverer  than you are you the measure of all  possible engineering solutions to  problems allow someone else to be  smarter than you to figure out how to  build it and when you do then the urge  to credit aliens diminishes